die NATO übt für den Ernstfall an ihrer
Ostflanke deutsche Leopard Panzer
kämpfen zusammen mit kroatischen
niederländischen und norwegischen
Einheiten
das ist einfach der beste Panzer wir
schießen besser wir treffen besser wir
sind schneller der Leopard 2 gilt auf
dem Schlachtfeld als gamechanger
dafür verantwortlich die Besatzung immer
weiter auszubilden das kann man hier auf
diesem Übungsplatz gut machen also dass
wir immer noch der beste Kampfpanzer des
Todes sind und hoffentlich auch bleiben
werden
im Mai 2023 Ruckler Litauen rund 100 km
von der russischen Grenze startet die
EFP Battlegroup der NATO die Übung iron
Wolf das ausgangsszenario die Invasion
eines Aggressors wurde zum Stillstand
gebracht ein tagelanger Gegenangriff
soll den Feind zurückbringen die
deutsche Panzerkompanie versteckt sich
mit zwei marderzügen und einem
leopard-zug vor der Aufklärung durch
feindliche Flugzeuge
[Musik]
wir bleiben weiter Verfügungsraum halten
uns hier immer noch versteckt wir haben
ja die flache angebracht damit wir von
oben nicht aufklärbar sind bis jetzt
scheint es auch zum Funktionieren der
Flieger Kreis war über uns wir kriegen
aber hier kein Stall vorher oder
ähnliches keine Bedrohung von oben wir
hoffen dass das so bleibt deswegen
halten wir weiterhin gedeckt und warten
immer noch auf die andere beginnen sie
warten an diesem Tag stundenlang
Kommandant an und seine Besatzung
Ladeschütze Christian Kraftfahrer
Dimitri und Richtschütze Clemens
Nachnamen gibt die Bundeswehr aus
Sicherheitsgründen nicht bekannt ihr
Leopard 2 ist ein Modell A6 also der
Panzer den Deutschland auch an die
Ukraine liefert um gegen die russischen
Invasionstruppen zu kämpfen diesen
Kampfpanzer da zu sehen und da
Erfahrungswerte zu schaffen oder zu
hören was damit passiert oder wie weit
der Konferenz ist oder nicht
oder ist überlegen
das finde ich schon spannend wir haben
ein vergleichschießen gehabt in Polen
ich muss mal Vergleich schießen gegen
Ape Rams oder mit Abrams und den PT 91
das ist der polnische T-72 die auch hier
als Feind da sind
keine Chance sie hat keine Chance kann
man nicht anders sagen ich weiß nicht ob
es eine Besatzung liegt an dem an dem
Ausbildungsstand dass unser höher ist
aber der kampfanze Leopard ist in meinen
Augen überlegen es ist einfach so
allerdings wissen wir auch selber dass
wir nicht viele Kampfpanzer haben und
wenn wir dann welche abgeben Schmerz ist
umso mehr
gerade das Bataillon hat nicht viele das
ist mein eigener wir kaufen den selber
mit Namen und wenn der dann abgegeben
wird ist das schon traurig sein
die Stimmung der Panzerbesatzung ist
auch im zweiten Tag der Übung gut sie
sind fokussiert die Engel im Panzer
stört hier niemanden
also der spürt meine Knie im Rücken und
davor sitzt noch der Kraftfahrer die
kann man jetzt schlecht sehen der sitzt
alleine in der Wanne sind zu dritt im
Turm und der Kraftfahrer sitzt unten
alleine der ist ein bisschen abgestattet
von uns der macht da sein eigenes Ding
sein immer
alle warten auf Position auf das Signal
zum Gegenangriff den Befehl bekommen Sie
dann per Funk von ihrem Kompaniechef
sondern zunächst hier hinter den hinter
den Norwegian hinterher und dann sollen
wir Richtung Süden wieder wegbrechen wir
fahren aber nicht den Beipass hier
runter wir fahren
Elektronen müssen
der Kompaniechef führt seine Einheit aus
einem führungspanzer der Vorstoß der
multinationalen Truppe beginnt
die deutschen Einheiten sollen später
folgen
die Koordination erfolgt ausschließlich
über Funk
ist auf jeden Fall
die deutsche Panzerkompanie soll gezielt
eingesetzt werden wenn möglich auf
freiem Feld also weil das jetzt nicht
unbedingt dass der Raum in dem sich
einen Kampf von so wohl fühlt sondern
sind ganz große offene weite Freiflächen
wo man wirklich mit seiner maximalen
Kampfentfernung von 4 bis 5000 Metern
auch gut den vollkampf führen kann und
wo kein feindicht an ihn dran kann das
sein Schutz seine Geschwindigkeit seine
auf seine physische Präsenz auch
wirklich zeigen kann und ja
Geschwindigkeit als Waffe nutzen kann
die NATO probt das Szenario Gegenangriff
nach einer Invasion feindlicher Truppen
im Baltikum Russland und Belarus nebenan
keine alltägliche Übung auch für die
Leopard 2 Besatzung umkommandantieren
dann auf einmal heißt es aufsitzen
Gefechtsbereitschaft herstellen dann
drückt das ganze schon näher hier weiß
man natürlich immer noch dass man in
einer Übung ist aber man merkt schon
auch bei den Kameraden die Spannung
steigt dann also die Leute sind dann
angespannter alles wird dann schneller
vielleicht etwas nervös aber dafür sind
wir ausgebildet worden der gut 64 Tonnen
schwere Leopard 2 kann auch erstaunlich
leise fahren bleibt dadurch lang
unbemerkt an diesem Tag trifft die
Besatzung von turtalk aber in einem
Waldstück auf ihre übungsgegner
polnische Infanterieeinheiten haben sich
hier mit ihren Truppen Transportern
verschweißt
Schiedsrichter begleiten mit
Geländefahrzeugen jede Kampfhandlung der
Übung alle teilnehmenden Länder stellen
Schiedsrichter sie bewerten neutral
Treffer und Wirkung legen auch
getroffene Fahrzeuge still wie zum
Beispiel hier links im Bild einen
deutschen Schützenpanzer er ist weniger
stark geschützt als der Leopard 2
der Leopard vereinigte diese diese drei
wichtigen Grundsätze das ist ja
Schnelligkeit vorher Kraft und
Beweglichkeit und gerade so in diesen
Gelände wenn man unter Luke geht der hat
ja auch guten Panzerschutz das heißt
dann dürfen schießen dann kommt das
nicht zwangsweise durch
nach dem Angriff geht es zurück in den
Verfügungsraum der Leopard 2 hat heute
seine technische Überlegenheit gegenüber
anderen Panzertypen auch zum Beispiel
russischer Bauart unter Beweis gestellt
wenn wir dann bei der angreifen dann
können wir die bootkanone auf ihn drauf
ziehen schießen ich kann in der Zeit
schon das nächste Ziel aufklären das ist
die sogenannte Hunter killerfähigkeit
und kann den Richtschützen das nächste
Ziel zuweisen das heißt das ist ein
Riesenvorteil von uns dass wir mit
Geschwindigkeit gleichzeitig dabei
schießen diese voll stabilisierte
Waffenanlage und dabei hilft wenn man
jetzt die Peter 91 zieht diesen
polnischen T-72 die fahren nicht
stabilisiert das geht nur bis zu einer
gewissen Geschwindigkeit bei denen und
längst nicht so gut wie bei uns ja das
heißt die sind da während der Fahrt
deutlich überlegen
Kommandant jan ist zufrieden mit dem
Übungsverlauf und der Trefferquote
seiner Besatzung
wir haben angegriffen haben Stellung
bezogen und ich habe halt polnische
Infanterie gesehen und habe ich mit dem
meinem Maschinengewehr drauf geschossen
dann noch mal mit dem BK also 120 mm
hinterher und dann hat er Schiri uns
nachher gesagt da war standen ganzer
polnischer und vertriebzug mindestens 25
Menschen also voller Direktschuss
Treffer also
das ist das was wir haben wollen
entweder sie oder wir denke ich mir dann
erstmal und dann ist ja besser dann wird
dass wir getroffen haben für heute ist
die Übung zu Ende du musste runterkommen
dann richtig gelitten hat ne der Regen
erfordert eine stabile planen
Konstruktion damit die Besatzung trocken
und die Stimmung gut bleibt die
Verpflegung wird für mehrere Tage
gebunkert es gibt wasserkekse und E-Pass
ein Mann Packungen
jetzt auch ich habe auch nichts gehört
je nachdem welches welchen Typ wir
gerade haben sind immer verschiedene
Sachen drin manchmal sind da Cookies mit
Vanillegeschmack oder mit mit Schoko und
manchmal sind auch diese Bananenchips
drin getrocknete Bananen die sind
tatsächlich ganz gut und noch zwei
Hauptgerichte sind dann immer mit drin
wir werden jetzt aber heute was haben
wir gehabt Hühnerfrikassee und äh
Bolognese ja Nudeln mit Bolognese Soße
ganz lecker kann man sich ganz schön
warm machen hier direkt vorne noch mal
auf den Backofen da genau warte hier ist
die Knarre ja auf Zeit
Wartungsdeckel vom Triebwerkraum wo wir
die Müll Ölstände prüfen also Getriebe
Motoröl und da kann man ganz gut die
Tüten reinpacken damit
ich kein Feuer machen oder sowas legen
wir das einfach rein
und jetzt da ganz gut sehen oben wird es
einfach drauf gelegt und dann nach ca 10
15 Minuten das ist schön warm man kann
das dann direkt genießen
keine Pause gibt es einige Kilometer
entfernt auf dem Übungsgelände die
Kommando Ebene
das ist der hauptgefechtstand ist
sozusagen die Spinne im Informationsnetz
in dem alle Informationen die
auf dem Gefechtsfeld auflaufen
zusammengeführt werden dabei geht es um
die feinlage es geht um eigene Kräfte wo
sie sich bewegen es geht um logistische
folgeversorgung Bergung die Versorgung
von Verwundeten etc
Oberstleutnant Neitzel ist der
Kommandeur der EFP Battlegroup in
Litauen sie wurde nach der russischen
Invasion in die Ukraine auf 1500
Soldaten aufgestockt der Auftrag das
Baltikum gegen einen möglichen Aggressor
verteidigen lassen Heizöl kommandiert
auch in der Übung den Gegenangriff der
nato-einheit sagen es ist wie die
Abteilung in einer Firma sie haben
Fachleute für unterschiedliche Bereiche
wir haben jemanden sich um die
gegnerischen Kräfte jemanden der kümmert
sich um Unterstützung durch
Luftfahrzeuge oder indirektes Feuer und
das Öffnen von sperren oder auch im
logistische folgeversorgung also
unterschiedlichste Zellen
unterschiedlichste Fähigkeiten sind hier
vereint um mir zu erlauben
Entscheidungen zu treffen im Ernstfall
Entscheidungen von denen Leben und Tod
abhängen wir können jetzt hier einmal in
die Operationszentrale gehen wo das
Gefecht zusammen läuft
die gefechtssprache ist englisch
die manöverpläne der Übung sollen geheim
bleiben ebenso wer Mitglied im
multinationalen Stab des Kommandeurs ist
sie haben im Grunde genommen einmal den
Bereich der Feindlage Beurteilung die
Beurteilung der eigenen Lage den Einsatz
von Stall vorher und den Einsatz von
pioniermitteln im Endeffekt haben sie
vier verschiedene Fachrichtungen die
hier in diesen beiden Zelten 24/7 also
durchgehend permanent eingesetzt sind
und hier ihren Dienst verrichten die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass so etwas
aufgeklärt wird das relativ groß weil
wenn sie sich draußen umgeschaut haben
versuchen wir die aufklärbarkeit durch
tarnmaßnahmen zu erschweren und diese
Einrichtung werden mindestens einmal
eher zweimal am Tag verlegt die
Zusammenarbeit in der Nato-Truppe hat
auch Schwachstellen z.B die
Kommunikation zwischen den armenien
multination ist das Herstellen einer
Funkverbindung zu einer anderen Nation
immer eine Herausforderung weil es um
Verschlüsselung und derartige Dinge geht
technische technische Dinge die nicht so
einfach zu lösen sind wo jede Nation
ihre eigenen Lösungen hat da sind wir
schon schon einige gute Schritte
vorangekommen ich glaube auch dass wir
als Battle Group da viele viele Schritte
in die richtige Richtung gemacht haben
aber wir sind noch lange nicht da dass
man sagen kann das funktioniert absolut
friktionsfrei und jederzeit kann jeder
mit jedem ohne irgendwelcher
Herausforderungen sprechen ein Problem
der multinationalen Truppe das auch bei
der Übung iron Wolf auftritt und
wichtige Abläufe verzögert wir haben die
Funkkontakt zu den Kroaten verloren das
heißt die sind vorne immer noch ein
Feuerkampf das heißt der Chef selbst ist
jetzt rausgefahren zu der Nachbar
Kompanie um den herzustellen das
Lagebild zu klären für uns bleibt die
Phase alles wie geplant der angeführt
wie geplant bei der stattfinden
wir waren jetzt tatsächlich nur noch auf
den anrufbeginn aber es wird kurz
bevorstehen jetzt
dann verlegt die deutsche Panzer
Kompanie in einen neuen Verfügungsraum
der Angriff beginnt
diesmal geht es über freies Gelände
an einem Waldrand haben sich gegnerische
Einheiten verschanzt
einen Leopard 2 können Sie mit einer
panzerbrechenden Waffe ausschalten
die drei verbliebenen brechen
unbeschadet durch sie beginnen ihre Jagd
auf die gegnerischen Panzer
[Musik]
die haben in einem Waldstück ihre
Stellungen bezogen
nein
gleichzeitig bekämpfen deutsche
Schützenpanzer vom Typen Marder die
gegnerischen Infanterieeinheiten im Wald
in den Fahrzeugen sind die
Panzergrenadiere geschützt vor kleineren
Waffen während ihre Panzer selbst mit 20
mm Maschinenkanonen verheerenden Schaden
anrichten können
am Ende erreicht die deutsche
Panzerkompanie im Verbund der
multinationalen Einheiten ihr geplantes
Ziel
zu den Holländern und Charlie er kann so
gut beobachten und wirken oder steht der
Panzer 12 Uhr kommen trotz Verlusten ein
gelungener Gegenangriff
gerade das was sie Aufklärung ergeben
hat und dass sie Scharfschützen waren ob
das die norwegische aufklärungskompanie
war alle die hier mit ihren Sensoren
auch die Holländer die hier mit Drohnen
aufgeklärt haben dazu geführt dass man
klares Lagebild hatten und dann gab es
einen Entschluss eines Kommandeurs und
da haben alle ja die Absicht umgesetzt
und mit Geschwindigkeit was dann immer
unsere Stärke ist entsprechend den Feind
überrascht beispielsweise sind die an
dem See wo wir ohne Sperre aufgeklärt
wurde abzusitzen diese frei zu kämpfen
und danach weiter anzugreifen mit den
Kampfpanzern im Zuge einer Freifläche
das hat der Vorrang funktioniert dieses
multinationale macht das auch extrem
spannend macht total Spaß werden jetzt
hier den niederländischen Kompaniechef
mit dem man quasi hat von Angesicht zu
Angesicht abspricht wo es gerade wer wer
hat welchen Auftrag wer kann wie wen
unterstützen und das macht halt Spaß und
bringt dann im immer wieder aus seiner
Komfortzone raus mal englisch zu
sprechen und nicht zu sagen wer bin ich
und wo wohne ich sondern äh
militärisches Englisch anzuwenden und
das ist anspruchsvoll aber es macht
total Spaß und den anderen
kennenzulernen wie wie was für ein
Absicht hat der Wiese die um
Freund erkennen was halt auch mit dazu
gehört und also ganz ganz viele
Erkenntnisse gerade das multi-nationale
die wir zu Hause nicht haben sondern nur
hier die Erfahrung machen können die
Motivation
und auch die geschlagenen gegnerischen
Soldaten nutzen die Gelegenheit die
Fahrzeuge der Bundeswehr aus der Nähe zu
sehen grüßen die übungsgegner schießen
Erinnerungsfotos der natoübung
die Leopard Panzer beziehen in das zur
Absicherung vorgeschobene Posten bleiben
dabei ständig in Bewegung nach
stundenlangen angriffsfahrten gehört
auch das noch zur Übung nach insgesamt
sechs Stunden im Dauerstress endet für
die leopardbesatzungen die Übung
tatsächlich ging es heute den ganzen Tag
zwischendurch gab es nochmal kurz
Unterbrechungen für mich wo ich mal
meinen Kopf für eine Sekunde ablenken
konnte das geht aber da muss man echt
sobald wir rollen muss ich die ganze
Zeit bei 100% bleiben anders geht's
nicht
und wenn sie weitergeht und weiter geht
und weiter geht
100% also ich kann es nicht ändern muss
man immer noch die Sprüche alle Filtern
wer ist jetzt mein Zugführer der ist
dann kann man ganz was ist wichtig für
mich wo muss ich sagen
egal ob es eine Stunde ist oder 10
Stunden muss ich halt drauf hören können
wenn wir jetzt in Deutschland kämpfen
kämpfen wenn man gegen Leopard 2 Panzer
und das ist schwierig zu unterscheiden
ist das einer von uns oder es ist ein
Gegner und hier ist das dann ein
bisschen einfacher weil wir gegen
russische Modelle kämpfen das ist
richtig gut gelaufen weil wir den Gegner
komplett überrascht haben die haben auf
ihrem Panzern gesessen die waren gar
nicht aufgesessen waren gar nicht
kampfbereit ja die waren wirklich
komplett überrascht dass wir da waren
und angegriffen haben wir sind jetzt
tatsächlich durch mit der Übung Wolf er
benutzen jetzt schnell die Zeit bevor
die Kompanie wieder reinmarschiert in
die TSA und äh kann schon mal ab das
heißt der ganze naturtande dran ist
damit wir im Gelände nicht so leicht
aufzuklären sind kommt jetzt schnell
runter wenn im Gelände genommen haben
schmeißen einfach wieder hin
und dann haben wir weniger Arbeit in der
nachtbereitung heute noch
tatsächlich die ist heute ganz gut wir
sind ja einen anderen Weg gefahren haben
wir den fein komplett umgangen und haben
den dann im Rücken erwischt das hat noch
gemerkt wie überrascht der war das heißt
die meisten Besatzung die haben eine
ganz andere Richtung geguckt haben uns
auch Geräusche nicht aufgeklärt aber
natürlich gefahren sind und haben dann
natürlich heute richtig hohe erfolgen
die Bundeswehr zeigt im Baltikum was sie
unter idealen Umständen zu leisten
imstande ist der Leopard 2 sei dabei nur
ein Element von vielen
[Musik]